ايها الشعله الاسرائيلي حيث قال رئيس
الوزراء من يمينه نتنياهو زعيمه حركه شاس
الدرعي من منصبه كوزيرا الداخليه والصحه
في الحكومه وكانت المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه قد قضت ببطلان تعيين الدرع
وزيرا في الائتلاف الحكومي وطلبت منه ان
يقيله كونه مدانا بالتهرب الضريبي والسرقه
وقد ادين زعيم حزب السياسي اليمني
المتشدده الدرعيه العام الماضي بالتهرب
الضريبي لكنه ليجنب السجن توصل الى اتفاق
مع المحكمه يقضي باقراره بالذنب ودفعه
غرامه قدرها 50,000 دولار
وبتنازله عن مقعده في الكنيست وقالت
المحكمه انه كان على درع عندما توصل الى
هذا الاتفاق ان يتقاعد من الحياه السياسيه
لكن الكنيست اقر الشهر الماضي قانونا يسمح
لاي شخص مدان بجريمه ولم يدخل السجن
بالحصول على حقيبه وزاريه بينما كان
القانون يحضر ذلك في السابق